but menachem adorable Naidu's a bit
looming dude we lose a bit lumpy -
nobody knows alerts that [ __ ] song
hey what is going on YouTube we in the
office today we're doing a video in the
office today with the food you like that
when I dance I'm all shoulders now
recently you guys sent me an interesting
video and I gotta tell you I'm not too
hyped about this because already the
title screwed me up
so by request from Janet Lynn I'm gonna
watch a video of a kangaroo choking the
[ __ ] out of a dog and if you guys have
been watching my channel you already
know I don't [ __ ] like kangaroos so
so let's watch this [ __ ] please you
okay that [ __ ] kangaroo looks like a
human being
[ __ ] that is not a king that is a that
is a bodybuilder in the kangaroo outfit
full-on [ __ ] head I told you
[ __ ] see that's not that's not
a [ __ ] normal animal things see what
he's he's young make prison did you go
to but a cranky [ __ ] comes forward ready
to attack [ __ ] again
first of all number one who the [ __ ]
socks a kangaroo in the face never in my
life would I ever think if I was
confronted by a wild animal when I put
my dukes up and slap shut up number one
I have a rational fear of kangaroo
contrary to popular belief it's rational
not irrational let me give you a few
reasons why look at the [ __ ] this
[ __ ] got a barbell for gang
membership and [ __ ] who the [ __ ] gave
this kangaroo steroids [ __ ]
looked like the Ct Fletcher of kangaroos
and [ __ ] this is one talking about if
the animal looks too [ __ ] human I
ain't trying to [ __ ] with it a kangaroo
is a bodybuilder with a [ __ ] tail and
I've read articles and stories about
kangaroos kicking the [ __ ] out of
somebody and literally exploding the rib
cage so why don't you tell me next time
when I shouldn't be afraid of a kangaroo
and I didn't understand why everybody
wants me to love a kangaroo I don't
wanna [ __ ] love a kangaroo what are
you like a coalition of kangaroo [ __ ]
out there that wants
me to suddenly be a kangaroo ambassador
I don't like the [ __ ] but in fact I
had a couple of comments from my Aussie
homies out that they were like oh if you
don't like kangaroos then obviously you
don't like Australian people [ __ ] that
[ __ ] was Australian and clearly
he did like kangaroos either I'll tell
you something else if my puppy wasn't a
chokehold by a kangaroo then you just
got choked you know what the funniest
[ __ ] part of this video was is when
the kangaroo got socked and he had that
face like what's this thing I have never
seen a kangaroo so shocking like I don't
even know cake Bruce could have facial
expressions and [ __ ] I'll tell you right
now this is not a racial comment leave
that [ __ ] up to white people y'all the
bravest [ __ ] on earth painting
lions and [ __ ] punching kangaroos in the
[ __ ] face going underwater petting
sharks what the hell is wrong with you I
have a homie that's about to go to
Hawaii soon and he said he's gonna go
out there and pet shudders you Chinese
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
doing some crazy white people said [ __ ]
oh my god you know why I don't pet Bubba
sharks because in the water from above I
have the silhouette of a plump seal you
fall and another thing - I don't gotta
[ __ ] like dolphins either I don't
understand why people are pressuring me
to like certain animals you know I don't
like dolphins
I don't want an animal that could learn
[ __ ] and then [ __ ] my ass over by the
way you know what dolphins are also
known as the rapists of the sea you can
you can you too right now dolphins
raping other dolphins that's how [ __ ]
up they are and they're not going to
jail for it saw another dolphin trying
to lick the coochie of another human or
have a human [ __ ] smiling this [ __ ] all
the time I love what a fish mammal done
smile under the watch of fish mammal you
know what that smile means it means i'ma
[ __ ] you in the ass that's what that
smile means it's just kangaroos are too
human-like you know what I'm sayin like
they got a six-pack they got to be small
as hell you guys remember that article
back in the day where they showed this
picture of this buff ass kangaroo no
kangaroo should look like that I just
picked this kangaroo inside a barbell
just having a conversation with Barton
[ __ ] today made up
all like kangaroos let it go
[Music]